There She Goes drag him slay
sister yes get that jerk in the muck
then the other ones go and they keep
trying to destroy the construction
equipment that sister oh I love it there
are too many pacifists in the church
militant if you ask me I absolutely love
that you know they say faith without
works is dead which is sometimes
misinterpreted to mean that we can earn
our own salvation through works and
that's not the case God's grace comes
all the way down the mountain we can
cooperate with that Grace or not and and
a a life of faith is going to look like
something and it's going to impel
certain actions such as tackling the
climate activists who are trying to
destroy your property and a beautiful
Chapel that could be built